[Music]
hi I'm Chet Haase an engineer on the
Android UI toolkit team today I'm going
to talk about a new animation feature in
the KitKat release it's called
transitions so the idea with transitions
is actually the idea behind a lot of the
stuff that we do which is trying to make
things easier for you the developers of
Android applications to get richer
experiences for your users hopefully
with less effort transitions it's kind
of a simple idea it's basically a way
for you to describe the different scenes
in your application either beforehand as
layout resource files or dynamically as
things change in the application and
then use transitions to animate the
changes no matter what those changes
were and you can step out of the way and
just let the transitions run
automatically without having to get more
involved and run these manual animations
which are more of the typical model of
animating things in a UI hopefully at
the end of the day you get richer
applications experiences by having more
stuff move on the screen in an intuitive
way your users get richer experiences
and they get a better understanding of
how your application actually works
because you can transition naturally
between these different scenes of your
application and and there's more
animations in the world which I'm always
in favor of okay so let's take a look at
some slides and we'll go over a very
quick overview of how the API works what
the different pieces are there's a lot
of details that I'm skipping here but
you are free and encouraged to check out
the details and the reference Docs and
articles on developer.android.com and
also API demos which we'll see a little
bit later we'll take a look at some code
in that okay so first we start out with
the idea of a scene you can think of
this as a layout it's basically a view
hierarchy that describes what this
particular scene looks like this could
be the scene of the entire application
in a particular screen or it could be
some sub hierarchy in this particular
case the scene describes this situation
where we have a textview an edit text
and a button fairly simple and then we
have another scene that we've described
through
with some other layout file we have
different text views in there a little
bit richer text longer details there but
we have again an edit text field and a
button and maybe these are shared
components maybe they moved location
possibly change size but they're
actually shared between the two scenes
wouldn't it be nice if you could help
the user understand as they move from
scene one to scene two in your
application the changes that it occurred
by fading things out that go away fading
things in that have come into being and
moving and resizing the shared elements
between these scenes that's what
transitions are about you specify these
different scenes and then when you go to
a scene the transition automatically
kicks in and runs the necessary
animations in order to to make that
change as well as to animate the change
over time so let's take a look at scenes
these are the modules that you've
defined for your application the
different screens if you will of states
that your application will move through
over time you can just construct these
scenes in different ways first of all
scenes always have a route or a view
group associated with them which is
basically the hierarchy under which the
scene lives and in which transitions
will take place so you can construct a
scene directly with that route and then
you can set an interaction and whenever
that scene is entered you will get a
call back into your runnable and you can
run whatever code you want to make
whatever manipulations you want to - the
view hierarchy fairly straight forward a
little bit more manual than the other
ways you can create scenes for example
you can create it from a view group
instead let's say you have inflated a
hierarchy from some layout ID you have
this view group sitting there you can
create a scene with that view group so
you give it basically two view groups
you can create it with the route of the
scene hierarchy as well as the route of
the the scene itself so pass that in
you've created scene you're good to go
so now when the scene is entered it will
simply change the scene to be to be
looking at that that view group instead
you don't need to tell it what to do to
manipulate the hierarchy it gets that
information from the view group that you
passed it in the constructor finally we
have something very similar to the last
one but instead of handing at a view
group you hand it
layout resource ID and when that scene
is entered it will inflate the resource
and it will go ahead and add that to the
scene route straightforward
the layout resource also kicks in if you
create scenes implicitly in resources
which we'll see a little bit later you
can have a transition manager that
automatically inflates scenes implicitly
given layout resource IDs and it uses
the same mechanism under the hood next
we can take a look at transitions these
are the engine responsible for declaring
what it is you want to do when things
change from scene to scene in your
application
so these basically listen for changes
before and after and compare those
values and then based on changes that
occurred to any view in the scene
hierarchy they'll create an animator
that then gets run to animate those
changes there's a few different ways to
create transitions you can just create
these things directly we have some
defines in the in the framework already
there's a change bounds which will move
and resize objects that change between
scenes there's a fade that will fade
things in and out according to whether
they come or go between scene changes
and then there's also a transition set
which is kind of the transition
equivalent of animator set it's
basically a group it's a way of
choreographing several different
transitions you can create a transition
set and then tell it to whether for all
of its transition children to run those
together or sequentially and it can also
be a hierarchy of sets so you can have a
much more complicated mechanism that
runs several transitions you know in
parallel or one after another to get a
more interesting animation experience
and finally you can load transitions
from resource files if that's the way
you go if you want to run it from
resources this is that this is how you
can do it you can this one for example
is a transition set that gets loaded
that has two children automatically
added to it to listen for changes in
visibility as well as size and location
the resource filed maybe it's not
something you want to do from code
because you're already in code and you
be it's easy enough to create these
things on the fly on the other hand this
is the mechanism that is used by
transition manager when in it inflates a
graph
the information which we'll see soon but
not on this slide yet
finally there's there's an idea of
custom transitions so we've defined as I
said a couple of canonical transitions
which which automatic transitions will
use on-the-fly there's change bounds
which moves and resizes views and
there's also fade which deals with
visibility information fades things in
and out fairly straightforward probably
the behavior you want in most cases but
if you want to define your own
transition for example if if when
something comes into being you didn't
want it to fade in in the middle of the
screen where it lives but you actually
wanted to slide it in from the right
then you can write a custom transition
you would simply subclass the transition
class itself and then you override the
three methods that do what it is you
want to do there's two capture methods
one captures the values at the start
when the when the application code said
okay I'm ready to do a transition that's
the point at which you would get a call
to your capture start values method and
you would go ahead and just read from
the view objects anything you wanted to
that affected your transition so you
could read the the layout position for
example or the visibility information
that you care about and then you get a
call to capture n values when the
transaction actually wants to run and
when it wants to start and then you
finally get a call right after that to
the create animator function which can
then compare those values and say okay
well this visibility value changed and
that's something that I care about
therefore I'm going to create an
animation that does the following you
know slides in from the right or
whatever it is returns that animator and
then the transition system runs it so
there's a lot of stuff that we just ship
with the framework for free and you can
simply use implicitly when you're in a
transition but if you want to create
custom transitions fairly
straightforward to do that the okay so
now you've got your scenes you've got
your transitions how do you actually
change scenes how do you go from one
scene to another you could just enter a
scene there's no transition involved
there you're basically just saying
here's the scene I want you to load and
it will do that it will run the code
that was in your runnable it will
inflate the the layout resource file
that you gave it whatever it'll enter
the scene nothing much going on there
certainly no interesting animations or
you can tell the transition manager to
go to a scene and in the process of
doing that it will use a default
transition along the way it'll say okay
I'm going to change into the scene and
in the meantime I'm going to capture
start values capture end values and run
the default transition for the system or
you can run it with a custom transition
you can say okay I've defined this
lovely transition that I want to use
when I'm going between this particular
scene combination and now go ahead and
transition using one of the one of the
one of the transition two or the go
methods in the transition manager and it
will actually load that new scene and
then run your custom transition along
the way before we get this transition
simplified there's one other thing that
I haven't mentioned here which is the
idea of a transition manager you'll
usually use this just for a one-off
thing where you say transition manager I
want to go to this scene and use my
custom transition here the other thing
that it can do is keep a whole graph of
information about all the transition
combinations that you want for all the
scene combinations that you have in your
application we'll see a little bit of
that in the demo later but I did want to
point out one final thing here on this
on this last exciting slide is that you
know with all this information all these
different classes to think about and
you've got scenes and you got
transitions but but really the idea is
to make animations simpler for most
development cases so in general the only
method that you probably are going to
care about is this one called transition
manager begin delayed transition and
then give it the scene route that you
want to run the transition on what that
does is kicks in all of the process that
is going to capture the current values
and then it's going to spawn a layout
and rendering run and then in the middle
of that frame it's going to capture the
end values figure out where things are
and then run an automatic transition for
you in most cases this is all that you
actually care about I it's basically a
dynamic change you can think of this as
creating and animating a dynamic scene
so instead of having these pre baked
scenes from layout resource IDs you can
basically say okay I want you to run a
transition so get ready and then in the
meantime I'm going to make a bunch of
changes and then by the time those
changes have actually kicked in measure
and layout has run
and the system is ready to draw the new
frame then the transitions kick in
figure out the deltas figure out the
changes and create the animations and
start the animations running fairly
straightforward one line of code nice ok
so now let's take a quick look at a demo
and this is one of the API demos that
ships with KitKat so you I would
encourage you to download this from the
samples and you can run this and play
with it to your heart's content
totally complicated an interesting demo
so we defined four scenes here and the
scenes use custom views so no particular
reason why these could be buttons I
happen to make them colored rectangles
instead so as we change between the
scenes you can see we're resizing we're
repositioning these things and we can
just change on the fly we're cancelling
we're interrupting we're running other
transitions so fairly straightforward
now let's take a look at the code for
that demo so there's a few different
pieces here first there's some layout
files so we have transitions scene 1
this just has a layout and it has 4
views inside their position
appropriately transition to scene 2
looks very similar to that it's just
different sizes and different positions
for the colored rectangles transition 3
adds the complication of also having
those grayscale custom views in the
middle there so nothing really
interesting going on in the layout
resource files but you'll see them
referred to later in the resources that
we inflate for the transition manager we
have some custom transition that we have
defined this is simply a change bounds
nothing really interesting here it's
just the standard change bounds that
we're going to run but we refer to this
resource later when we inflate the
transition manager here's a little bit
more interesting one this is a
transition set it's going to run in the
default mode where all the transitions
run in parallel it's going to run a
change bounds at the same times it's
going to run a fade transition and the
fade is going to be targeted at a
specific view and we use IDs to
associate with views and so that means
the fade is not generally applied to
everything
on the screen but we're saying hey I
want you to run this specific transition
on this specific view in the hierarchy
fade-out is very similar although in
this case it's going to run the
transition sequentially so he's going to
run the change bounds on any things that
change position in size and after that's
done it's going to run the fade and then
finally we have a transition manager
which we haven't really seen yet this is
the the object that keeps a graph of
what you want to happen as you go from
scene to scene in your application you
can define here I mean if if you don't
need any custom transitions then you
wouldn't care about transition manager
you would just run transitions but if
you care that when you go from scene one
- same - you want this particular custom
transition but from scene due to scene 3
you want a different one this is how you
would define it at least in resource
files so you create a transition manager
and then you have several transition
objects that define the interaction that
you want in any of these particular
scenes scene changes so we have a from
scene that refers to a layout file and
that's implicitly going to inflate that
layout resource file and create a scene
out of it we have a two scene same thing
it's going to create a scene from that
layout file and then we have the
transition that it's going to refer to
in another transition resource file like
the ones that we just looked at so
that's all the resource stuff now let's
look at the code which is in transitions
Java and in the API demos you'll see
this in the animations directory and
it's called simple transitions and here
it is not a lot of code going on here we
inflate the transition manager well we
get the transition inflator and then we
inflate the transition manager down here
and we also create three scenes along
the way and you'll note we're only
creating three scenes but there were
actually four in the demo and we'll show
why in a minute
the only reason that we need the scenes
in the in the code here is that this is
where we specify that we're going to
transition to a particular scene we've
already told the transition manager what
transitions to run as we go scene to
scene and here we're actually getting a
reference to those scenes and saying ok
now I want to move to scene 1 scene to
scene 3 and we do that down here when we
click on the radio button and the demo
we get a call to one of these items and
we say ok Tran
in manager I want you to transition to
the next scene and it'll go it'll load
the scene it will figure out the changes
and run the transition that we specified
in the transition manager resource file
that we saw finally there is a fourth
scene in there that has nothing to do
with these scene objects that we
inflated but instead this is what I
referred to before as a dynamic scene
because we're basically changing the
view hierarchy on-the-fly and having the
transition manager or the transition
system in general basically
automatically animate all the changes
there we call the magic method called
but--can delayed transition we handed a
scene route that we're going to operate
on we call this helper method called set
new size and basically we make arbitrary
changes inside the view hierarchy this
comes in here it set some new layout
parameters on the views this will spawn
a request layout internally things
inside the the scene route will end up
being relayed out and be rendered and
when that happens transition system
notice that things have changed and it
runs transitions automatically as you
saw in the demo things move around
things resize with this single line of
code
so that's transitions it's a new feature
in KitKat
I anticipate it will be worked on more
as time goes on it's fairly
straightforward and simple for now and
hopefully more importantly simple for
you to use to make richer Android
applications thanks